- Oh, I know what mine tastes like.
You know right after you
puke when you're drunk,
and you get, like residual--
- Yes!
- Bile.
- Bile, like spicy alcohol.
- Yeah.
- That's what this is.
- But it's healthy for you, so what?
(gritty rock music)
- Do we shoot it?
How are we supposed to do it?
- Wait, so when I put it in my mouth,
you put it in your mouth?
- I'm just gonna shoot it.
- Alright.
- Tastes like Martinelli's.
- Shit wasn't that bad. It tastes amazing.
- This was at the bottom of mine.
- So you got the fungus in this one?
- Am I gonna trip?
Am I gonna trip?
- No, you didn't eat it.
Alright, let's do it.
(gritty rock music)
- Yo, no!
- Wow, this smells rich.
- This is like, alien guts!
- Cheers, all right? Go, boom.
- Oh, that's so,
(gurgles)
- I love it.
- The texture's horrible!
- I think the texture's fun as fuck!
- That's fun! This reminds me of
the medicine I used to
have when I was sick.
- That usually isn't something
that people like the taste of.
- Well, it was the grape medicine.
It was really good!
(squealing)
- It's super fun!
- It is super fun.
- Imagine doing that with somebody,
back and forth in their mouth.
- You wanna try it?
- Do it, do it!
- I can't, I can't, I can't. I can't.
- I woulda committed. I commit, I commit.
(gritty rock music)
(all singing)
- Kombucha!
Well, ours looks like Gatorade,
and Kelsey's looks like pond water.
- Yeah, right?
- Slip it off my finger.
- Ew!
- Oh. This tastes fantastic.
- No!
- Somebody taste mine,
and tell me it tastes like ya'lls.
- Mine's spicy.
- It looks like somebody bottled a puddle.
- It's like healthy soda.
- Like healthy soda.
- That you threw up.
- Yes.
- It's like healthy
soda that you threw up.
- [all together] Kombucha.
(gritty rock music)
- Anybody smell toast?
I smell toast.
- Are you having a seizure?
- Oh my god!
(laughter)
(logo creaking)